Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
What are datasets?
A dataset is typically a big bunch of data,
for instance, a database of written letters,
digits, images of human faces, stock market
data that scientists can use to test their
algorithms on.
If two research groups wish to find out whose
algorithm performs better at recognizing traffic
signs, they run their techniques on one of
these datasets and test their methods on equal
footings.
For instance, the CamVid dataset stands for
Cambridge-driving Labeled Video Database,
and it offers several hundreds of images depicting
a variety of driving scenarios.
It is meant to be used to test classification
techniques: the input is an image, and the
question is for each of the pixels, which
one of them belongs to what class.
Classes include roads, vegetation, vehicles,
pedestrians, buildings, trees and more.
These regions are labeled with all the different
colors that you see on these images.
To have a usable dataset, we have to label
tens of thousands of these images, and as
you may imagine, creating such labeled images
requires a ton of human labor.
The first guy has to accurately trace the
edges of each of the individual objects seen
on every image, and there should be a second
guy to cross-check and make sure everything
is in order.
That's quite a chore.
And we haven't even talked about all the other
problems that arise from processing footage
created with handheld cameras, so this takes
quite a bit of time and effort with stabilization
and calibration as well.
So how do we create huge and accurate datasets
without investing a remarkable amount of human
labor?
Well, hear out this incredible idea.
What if we would record a video of us wandering
about in an open-world computer game, and
annotate those images.
This way, we enjoy several advantages:
- 1.
Since we have recorded continuous videos,
after annotating the very first image, we
will have information from the next frames,
therefore if we do it well, we can propagate
a labeling from one image to the next one.
That's a huge time saver.
- 2.
In a computer game, one can stage and record
animations of important, but rare situations
that would otherwise be extremely difficult
to film.
Adding rain or day and night cycles to a set
of images is also trivial, because we simply
can query the game engine to do this for us.
- 3.
Not only that, but the algorithm also has
some knowledge about the rendering process
itself.
This means that it looks at how the game communicates
with the software drivers and the video card,
tracks when the geometry and textures for
a given type of car are being loaded or discarded,
and uses this information to further help
the label propagation process.
- 4.
We don't have any of the problems that stem
from using handheld cameras.
Noise, blurriness, problems with the lens,
and so on are all non-issues.
Using this previous CamVid dataset, the annotation
of one image takes around 60 minutes, while
with this dataset, 7 seconds.
Thus, the authors have published almost 25000
high-quality images and their annotations
to aid computer vision and machine learning
research in the future.
That's a lot of images, but of course, the
ultimate question arises: how do we know if
these are really high-quality training samples?
They were only taken from a computer game
after all!
Well, the results show that using this dataset,
we can achieve an equivalent quality of learning
compared to the CamVid dataset by using one
third as many images.
Excellent piece of work, absolutely loving
the idea of using video game footage as a
surrogate for real-world data.
Fantastic.
And in the meantime, while we're discussing
computer graphics, here's a nice computer
graphics challenge grant from Experiment.
Basically, if you start a new research project
through their crowdfunded system, you may
win additional funding that comes straight
for them.
Free money.
If you are interested in doing any kind of
research in this area, or if you are a long-time
practitioner, make sure to have a look.
The link is available in the video description
box.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!